now let me tell you matt you saw how he
was talking to me right when we were on
the show yeah for his smile then he
he tweeted me oh what did he say
well it was about your show but it still
had my name in it
he tweeted me
something something came with me i can't
remember it but it was something
fantastic
so um i want to uh
slide in this dm and i need you to help
me oh okay well i don't know how i can
help i'm a wreck
no you got this okay okay so this way i
got my phone we're gonna make up a video
right
okay okay you ready so this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna i'm gonna act
like i'm singing
okay you gonna say the words and i'm
gonna be mouthing them
that's what i need you to say okay i
need you to say hey
matt hey matt those other girls are
whack
why don't you come and get a little of
this back fat
wait you got it you've got to end it
with something to hold on to
oh yes okay all right that's why it's
there the lord knew
the lord knew okay so you you okay
you're saying i wouldn't be in it you
think okay yeah okay here we go here we
go
you gotta help me okay hey matt
those other girls away get you some back
fight
something to hold on to look at that
meat oh look at that meat
[Laughter]
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure